Catherine Buettner brings all her data
with her to work encrypted on her laptop
together with her partner Sharif teeb
she's developed a simple modular
software system for setting up websites
the young entrepreneurs share office
space in central Berlin with other young
programmers their ideas and business
strategies however are closely held
secrets secured unprotected hard drives
that wasn't always the case the two
first had to learn a tough lesson speech
doesn't centolla
data security is key to our work we had
to learn that though we used to chat
about our ideas with others or use
hotspots or leave our computers lying
around
then we found parts of our product on
other people's websites it was a steep
learning curve a competitor launched a
very similar site with the stolen data
the young programmers nearly lost a
significant part of their client base
this expertise is the basis of our
existence we've invested a lot of blood
sweat and tears we've also taken on big
financial burdens and put a huge amount
of time into this Fe it's heightened
list yet from structural designs to
control software for production
facilities nowadays almost all of the
company's important data is stored
somewhere in digital form and that means
it can be hacked bernhard pizza is a
very busy man he advises medium-sized
businesses on how to handle sensitive
data the revelations of us spying
activities in Europe have many companies
worried replicas software is in demand
it allows users to exchange and store
sensitive information in a secure data
space for many SMEs having a unique
selling point is everything and there
are many German firms that have an
exclusive one in the car industry in
mechanical engineering and so on if
their products were copied it would
threaten the company's very existence
together with partners Berger conducted
a study it revealed that around 1 SME in
5 has detected attacks on its data in
the past the security experts assume
many more go unnoticed just having a
data leak can cause a company to lose
contracts especially if clients don't
feel confidential information is safe
these companies involve lots of
innovation with a great deal of
knowledge about production methods and
processes in a highly industrialized
world if the differences between
technologies are no longer that large so
information is key who are the best
subcontractors and lucrative clients and
what are the margins that's the data
attackers are trying to get no one knows
exactly how many cyber attacks on German
companies are successful but the
Federation of German industry assumes
the country's businesses are attractive
targets for industrial ackers all over
the world it's hard for us to estimate
the damage done to German industry
through industrial espionage and cyber
security issues but the Interior
Ministry believes it costs between 20
and 50 billion euros annually unreported
damages could drive that number way up
but the startup entrepreneurs in Berlin
don't just rely on strong encryption
when their data was stolen only good
relations with clients helped them
through the crisis now they've made
personal interaction with customers a
cornerstone of their business strategy